♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WHEN DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY ALL OF A
SUDDEN START TO PULL BACK THEIR
MASK MANDATES, THEY DID IT
VIRTUALLY OVERNIGHT AND THEY DID
IT IN UNISON, WE NATURALLY
ASSUMED THAT NEW POLLING HAD TO
BE BEHIND IT, SOMEONE AT THE DNC
MUST HAVE SEEN TERRIFYING PUBLIC
OPINION NUMBERS AND DECIDED TO
ABANDON PROJECT QUARANTINE
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTION.
THAT MADE SENSE TO US.
WE EXPLAINED THAT THEORY ON THE
SHOW LAST NIGHT.
WE STILL THINK IT'S PROBABLY
TRUE.
BUT IT'S ALSO CLEAR AS OF
TONIGHT THAT THERE IS
EXPLANATION FOR THIS.
DEMOCRATS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
LOOKING NORTH TO THEIR FRIENDS
IN THE RULING PARTY OF CANADA,
AND WHAT THEY SEE THERE SCARES
THEM.
CANADA'S WORKING CLASS HAS
FINALLY REBELLED AFTER YEARS OF
HER LIGHTLESS ABUSE.
TRUCK DRIVERS ARE THREATENING TO
TOPPLE JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S CREEPY
LITTLE GOVERNMENT WITH THEIR BIG
RIGS, AND THEY MAY SUCCEED,
ACTUALLY.
THE PROTEST AGAINST HIS VACCINE
MANDATES HAVE BEEN FAR MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN ANYONE IN CHARGE
IMAGINE.
FOR DEMOCRATS IN THE
UNITED STATES, THAT'S A PRETTY
OBVIOUS LESSON.
OVER THE PAST 48 HOURS, CANADIAN
TRUCKERS HAVE BLOCKED THE MAJOR
TRADE ROUTES BETWEEN THEIR
COUNTRY AND OURS.
LAST NIGHT FARMERS DRIVING HEAVY
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT CHECKED
ON THE HIGHWAYS AT THE MANITOBA
BORDER WITH THE UNITED STATES.
YOU'RE SEEING FOOTAGE NOW FROM
THE TOWN OF EMERSON MANITOBA.
1100 MILES AWAY, A SIMILAR SCENE
ON THE BORDER OF ONTARIO IN THE
UNITED STATES.
GREEN TRACTORS WITH CANADIAN
FLAGS LINING THE HIGHWAY IN
PROTEST.
BUT THE MOST MEANINGFUL BLOCKADE
OF ALL IS TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW
ON THE AMBASSADOR BRIDGE, THE
PRIVATELY OWNED SPAM THAT
CONNECTS DETROIT TO WINDSOR,
ONTARIO.
IF YOU LIVE IN THE UPPER
MIDWEST, YOU KNOW IT WELL.
A QUARTER OF ALL THE TRADE
BETWEEN UNITED STATES AND
CANADA, ONE OF THE WORLD'S
BIGGEST TRADING PARTNERS,
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, COMES
ACROSS THAT BRIDGE.
AS MOLLY LINE IS REPORTING FROM
OTTAWA, THAT BRIDGE IS NOW
COMPLETELY SHUT DOWN.
>> WE ARE CANADIAN AND WE WANT
TO BE FREE CANADIANS.
>> INCREASING CONCERN SPREADING
THROUGH CANADA AND NOW THE U.S.
AS THE FREEDOM CONVOY BRETONS
TRADE ALONG THE BORDER.
TRUCKERS BLOCKING TRAFFIC AT THE
AMBASSADOR BRIDGE CONNECTING
DETROIT AND ONTARIO, A SECOND
CROSSING LINKING ALBERTA AND
MONTANA CALLING FOR AN END TO
ALL COVID RESTRICTIONS AND
VACCINE MANDATES.
>> WE WILL HAVE FREEDOM, FREEDOM
OF ALL MANDATES AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE FIGHTING FOR.
>> THE AMBASSADOR BRIDGE IS THE
BUSIEST INTERNATIONAL CROSSING
IN NORTH AMERICA KAREN 25% OF
ALL TRADE BETWEEN CANADA AND THE
U.S.
>> Tucker: WE WANT FREEDOM,
THE TRUCKERS ARE SAYING, FREEDOM
FROM MANDATES.
IT'S A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD ASK,
BUT SO FAR THE TRUCKERS DON'T
HAVE THAT FREEDOM AND SO THERE
BLOCKADE CONTINUES.
SO FAR, THAT BLOCKADE HAS FORCED
FORWARD MOTORCADE -- TO OPERATE
ANOTHER PLANT WITH A SKELETON
CREW.
TOYOTA SAYS IT WILL BE ABLE TO
MANUFACTURE VEHICLES AND ONTARIO
FOR THE REST OF THE WEEK.
GENERAL MOTORS HAS CANCELED
MULTIPLE SHIFTS AT ITS PLANT IN
MICHIGAN DUE TO HEART SHORTAGES.
SO THIS PROTEST IS LESS THAN A
WEEK OLD AND ALREADY IS CAUSING
DEEP PAIN TO AT LEAST ONE GLOBAL
INDUSTRY.
IT'S HARD TO OVERSTATE THE
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE OF WHAT
WE'RE WATCHING RIGHT HERE.
THE CANADIAN TRUCKER CONVOY IS
THE SINGLE MOST SUCCESSFUL HUMAN
RIGHTS PROTEST IN A GENERATION.
IF NOTHING ELSE, IT HAS BEEN A
VERY USEFUL REMINDER TO OUR
ENTITLED RULING CLASS THE
WORKING CLASS MAN CAN BE PUSHED,
BUT ONLY SO FAR.
WHEN THEY PUSH BACK, IT HURTS.
IT TURNS OUT THAT TRUCK DRIVERS
ARE MORE IMPORTANT TO A
COUNTRY'S FUTURE THAN SAY
DIVERSITY CONSULTANTS OR EVEN AN
MSNBC CONTRIBUTOR.
NEW.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS NO INTEREST
IN KNOWING.
ACCORDING TO THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS TONIGHT, THE
BIKE DEMONSTRATION IS "URGING"
THE TRUDEAU GOVERNMENT TO USE
ITS FEDERAL POWERS TO STOP THIS
PROTEST.
TO END THE PROTEST.
IN OTHER WORDS, CRUSH THEM BY
FORCE.
POLITICO IS REPORTING THAT BIDEN
OFFICIALS ARE COORDINATING WITH
CANADIAN AUTHORITIES TO
"ESTABLISH ALTERNATE TRAFFIC
ROUTES" AROUND THE PROTESTERS.
SCRANTON JOE, THE PROUNION GUY
SHUTTING DOWN A LABOR ACTION.
PETE BUTTIGIEG IS THE COMPLETELY
INCOMPETENT TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY IN THIS COUNTRY,
APPARENTLY IN CHARGE OF THIS
EFFORT.
BUT HE DOES NOT REALIZE IS IT'S
NOT SO EASY.
TRUCK DRIVERS KNOW A LOT MORE
ABOUT ROADS THAN McKINSEY
CONSULTANTS DO.
THE ALTERNATIVE BORDER CROSSING
IN ALBERTA HAS ALREADY BEEN
TOTALLY SHUT DOWN.
THEY THOUGHT OF THAT ALREADY.
THE BLUE WATER BRIDGE WHICH
CONNECTS ONTARIO TO MICHIGAN HAS
BEEN REPORTING DELAYS TONIGHT OF
NEARLY FIVE HOURS.
THERE IS AN OBVIOUS WAY TO FIX
THIS PROBLEM.
MATTHEW MARIN IS THE OWNER OF
THE AMBASSADOR BRIDGE INTO
MICHIGAN, JUST SPELLED IT UP FOR
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, WHO IS NOT
TERRIBLY BRIGHT.
AND THE VACCINE MANDATES AND THE
BRIDGE REOPENS.
IT'S NOT HARD.
BUT JUSTIN TRUDEAU WON'T.
AND HE'S DECIDED HE DOESN'T HAVE
TO.
BECAUSE THE TRUCKERS, AS HE'S
EXPLAINED, HAVE NO LEGITIMATE
COMPLAINT.
THEY ARE RACISTS, SO WE ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO LISTEN TO THEM.
HERE IS TRUDEAU IN THE CANADIAN
PARLIAMENT ON MONDAY.
>> PEOPLE OF OTTAWA DON'T
DESERVE TO BE HARASSED IN THEIR
OWN NEIGHBORHOODS.
THEY DON'T DESERVE TO BE
CONFRONTED WITH THE INHERENT
VIOLENCE OF A SWASTIKA FLYING ON
A STREET CORNER FOR A
CONFEDERATE FLAG, OR THE INSULTS
AND JEERS JUST BECAUSE THEY
AREN'T WEARING A MASK.
THAT'S NOT WHO CANADA AND
CANADIANS ARE.
>> Tucker: OH, SO THEY ARE NOT
EVEN REALLY CANADIANS.
THEIR.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO HEAR
ANYTHING THEY SAY.
THEY DON'T EVEN BELONG HERE,
MAYBE WE WILL IN TURN THEM OR
EXPEL THEM.
TRUDEAU STATE BROADCASTERS HAVE
BEEN REPEATING HIS LIES OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR MAXIMUM
EFFECT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
WHAT'S STRIKING HOWEVER IS THE
MEDIA AND OUR COUNTRY CLAIM TO
BE INDEPENDENT BUT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING THE VERY SAME THING.
WATCH.
>> SOME OF THE ORGANIZERS OF
THIS PROTEST, WHICH AS I
MENTIONED STARTED MORE THAN A
WEEK AGO, THEY DO WANT TO
OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT.
>> CANADIAN OFFICIALS CALLING
THE SITUATION A "NATIONWIDE
INSURRECTION."
>> THE POLICE CHIEF SAYS COVID
PROTESTS ARE A NATIONWIDE
INSURRECTION DRIVEN BY MADNESS.
>> NATIONWIDE INSURRECTION
DRIVEN BY MADNESS.
THE LANGUAGE, I KNOW IT SOUNDS
FAMILIAR TO YOU, A THREAT TO,
AND INSURRECTION.
>> THE POLICE SAY THAT THEY ARE
UNDER RESOURCED AND OVERWHELMED.
THEY SAID THAT IT'S UNDER SIEGE.
>> I'VE HEARD THERE'S CUMIN ON
SUPPORTERS THE CROWD, RESIDENTS
THAT I HAVE SPOKEN TO WHO SAY
THEY FEEL TERRORIZED,
INTIMIDATED.
>> IT'S OCCULT.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE QANON
SUPPORTERS IN THE CROWD.
IT'S A CULT!
THEY ARE NAZIS AND THEY ARE
CRAZY.
INSURRECTIONIST ON THE BRIDGE!
THEY ARE USING THESE SMEARS
BECAUSE TYPICALLY THEY WORK.
JUST DISMISS THESE PEOPLE, DON'T
LISTEN TO THEM.
THEY DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE.
BUT WHAT JUSTIN TRUDEAU
APPARENTLY DIDN'T COUNT ON IS
THAT A HANDFUL OF INDEPENDENT
JOURNALISTS ARE COMMITTING
JOURNALISM INSIDE CANADA.
AND A FREE PRESS WORKS.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE IT, OR DID.
SO INSTEAD OF REPEATING
STATE-MANDATED TALKING POINTS
LIKE THEIR JOURNALISTS DO AND
THE IN OUR PRESS CORPS DO, THESE
INDEPENDENT REPORTERS HAVE BEEN
BROADCASTING HOURS LONG
INTERVIEWS WITH THE TRUCKERS
THEMSELVES IN THEIR CABS TOTALLY
INSULTED, SO YOU CAN DECIDE WHAT
YOU THINK.
YOU CAN ASK A MAKE YOUR OWN
JUDGMENT ABOUT REALITY.
SO YOU WATCH THE STREAMS FOR
JUST A FEW MINUTES AND YOU
REALIZE THIS TRUCKERS, WHATEVER
THEIR FAULTS MAY BE, ARE FAR
LESS ODIOUS AND MUCH HARDER
WORKING THAN THE JOURNALISTS AND
THE POLITICIANS WHO CALL THEM
NAZIS.
HERE'S 124-YEAR-OLD PROTESTER
WHO SAVED UP AND BOUGHT A TRUCK.
HE'S LOSING HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS
EVERY DAY BECAUSE HE'S NO LONGER
WORKING BUT HE SAYS IT'S WORTH
IT BECAUSE HE'S MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS THAN ABOUT
HIS OWN PAYCHECK.
YOU DECIDE.
>> I AGREE WITH FREEDOM OF
CHOICE.
SO IF YOU WANT TO WEAR A DIAPER
OVER YOUR FACE, GO AHEAD.
YOU CAN WEAR A FACE DIAPER IF
YOU WANT, BUT WHY SHOULD I
BECAUSE OF YOUR FEAR OF GOT TO
WEAR THAT GARBAGE ON MY FACE.
DOING THAT FOR TWO YEARS, THEY
SAID TWO WEEKS.
IT'S TURNED INTO TWO YEARS.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> Tucker: THE VOICE OF THE
WORKINGMEN THERE.
YOU KNOW HOW WE KNOW HE'S A
NAZI?
BECAUSE HE USED THE WORD
FREEDOM.
THAT WAS NOT SHOT BY THE CDC, IT
WAS FROM A LIVE STREAM ON THE
YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
IT WAS FILMED JUST AFTER
MIDNIGHT THIS MORNING.
IT IS RUN BY A MAN YOU'VE NEVER
HEARD OF CALLED MATT GARCIA.
GARCIA IS ONE OF A HANDFUL OF
INDEPENDENT YOUTUBE CHANNEL
OPERATORS WHO ARE DOING -- WHO
THE LEGACY MEDIA REFUSES TO DO
ANYWHERE, EVERYWHERE ANYMORE.
GARCIA ACTUALLY TALKS TO PEOPLE,
HE REPORTS.
HE'S NOT PAID TO DO THIS, HE'S
DOING IT BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE
WILL DO IT.
YOU SHOULD WATCH IT, IT'S
COMPELLING, BECAUSE YOU CAN HEAR
PEOPLE SPEAK AND YOU CAN DECIDE
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY
HAVE TO SAY.
HERE'S ANOTHER PROTESTER THAT
GARCIA SPOKE TO ON THE STREETS
OF OTTAWA.
THIS MAN SAYS THAT
JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S AUTHORITARIAN
BEHAVIOR REMINDS HIM OF THE
AYATOLLAHS IN THE COUNTRY HE
LEFT, WHICH IS IRAN.
WATCH.
>> I'M FROM IRAN, AND I AM PROUD
TO BE A CANADIAN FREEDOM LOVING
PATRIOT.
I CAME HERE FROM -- I DID A
SPEECH ON THE STAGE AND I LOST
MY FREEDOM ONCE IN A RUN, BY THE
AYATOLLAHS.
I DON'T WANT TO LOSE MY FREEDOM
AGAIN IN CANADA.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT'S THE
ANSWER TO HIM?
IS HE IN QANON?
IS HE A WHITE SUPREMACIST?
CANADA'S LEADERS HAVE NO
RESPONSE WHATSOEVER.
THEY JUST ACCUSE ALL THESE
PEOPLE OF BIGOTRY, AND THEN THEY
TURN AWAY.
THE PROTESTERS ARE SO IMMORAL WE
HAVE NO OBLIGATION TO LISTEN TO
THEM BECAUSE DEMOCRACY.
WE ALL LOSE WHEN THEY DO THAT,
BECAUSE ACTUALLY THE TRUCKERS DO
HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY.
SOME OF THEM ARE PRETTY
ARTICULATE.
SOME OF THEM ARE EVEN ELOQUENT
ABOUT WHAT THEY WANT.
SO AS A PUBLIC SERVICE WE
THOUGHT YOU WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
IT, HERE IT IS.
>> SOMETHING EXTREME ABOUT
WANTING PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS IN
THEIR HOME, THAT IS THE BEST
DECISION FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
THERE'S NOTHING EXTREME ABOUT
THAT.
>> Tucker: NO, THAT'S NOT
EXTREME.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE EXTREMISM,
TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT HOW
CANADA'S RULING CLASS IS
RESPONDING TO THESE DECIDEDLY
NOT EXTREME PROTESTS.
AUTHORITIES IN CANADA ARE NOW
STEALING FIREWOOD FROM
PROTESTERS IN SUBZERO
TEMPERATURES.
YOU'RE SEEING THAT THEFT ON YOUR
SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE NOT MAKING IT UP.
THAT WHAT IS NOT BEING USED IN A
CRIME.
THEY ARE NOT USING IT TO ROB
LIQUOR STORES, THE PROTESTERS
ARE USING THE WOOD TO KEEP FROM
FREEZING TO DEATH IN FEBRUARY.
BUT TRUDEAU'S ENFORCERS JUST
TOOK IT FROM THEM.
THEY ALSO SEIZED FUEL, WHICH THE
TRUCKERS WERE USING TO KEEP FROM
DYING IN THEIR CABS OVERNIGHT.
WATCH.
>> YOU TAKE THOSE CABS OFF OF
THAT TRUCK, IS THAT YOUR
PROPERTY?
IT IS NOW!
SO YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO TAKE
GAS CANS OFF OF A TRUCKER'S
TRUCK, IS THAT CORRECT?
IT IS CORRECT.
ACCORDING TO WHAT?
AIDING AND ABETTING CRIMINALS?
A CRIMINAL OFFENSE?
SO YOU HAVE GAS CANS ON YOUR
TRUCK, IT'S A CRIMINAL OFFENSE.
>> Tucker: LET'S SAY YOU ARE
IN AMERICAN TELEVISION OR YOU
LIZ CHENEY OR ANY ONE OF THE
MANY PEOPLE WHO LECTURE YOU
EVERY DAY ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
WHAT WOULD YOU MAKE OF THAT
EXCHANGE?
YOU MAY NOT LIKE THE GUY'S BEARD
OR WHO HE VOTED FOR, BUT WHAT'S
ANSWER TO HIM?
IF POLICE ARE BREAKING THE LAW
BY ENFORCING AN ORDER FROM THE
GUY WHO RUNS THE COUNTRY, IS
THAT A DEMOCRACY?
NO.
IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT A FREE COUNTRY, IT'S A
VERY SCARY PLACE, AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT CANADA HAS BECOME
UNDER JUSTIN TRUDEAU.
WE WILL PLAY ONE MORE CLIP.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THESE BUT WE
ARE NOT GOING TO DRAG IT OUT.
YOU SEE THE POINT.
WATCH THIS ONE.
THESE ARE POLICE ACTING UNDER
JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S ORDERS DRAGGING
AN ELDERLY MAN TO JAIL AND
HURTING HIM ALONG THE WAY.
WHY?
BECAUSE HE DARED TO HONK HIS
HORN IN SUPPORT OF THE TRUCKERS.
>> WHAT'S YOUR NAME AND BADGE
NUMBER?
YOU'RE HURTING AN OLD MAN!
A CANADIAN CITIZEN!
COMMUNISM!
THIS IS COMMUNISM, HE'S SCARED.
[BLEEP] COMMUNIST.
COLLIER POLICE CHIEF, HE WILL
BACK YOU UP.
CALL YOUR POLICE CHIEF.
ARRESTING AN OLD MAN?
SHAME ON YOU!
>> Tucker: THEY HURT HIM TOO.
LOOK UP HIS BRUISES ON THE
INTERNET.
IN THE END, CANADIANS ARE NICE
PEOPLE, THE CLICHE IS TRUE, AND
THEY ARE SEEING SOME OF THIS.
IT'S BEING HIDDEN FROM THEM ON
THE STATE MEDIA BUT IT'S ALL ON
THE INTERNET.
SO JUSTIN TRUDEAU IS ATTACKING
HUMAN RIGHTS AND ATTACKING
HUMANS, AND THAT ULTIMATELY IS
BOUND TO PROVOKE A BACKLASH.
AND IT IS.
THE PROVINCE OF ALBERTA JUST
ANNOUNCED IT IS LIFTING ITS
COVID RESTRICTIONS AND SCRAPPING
ITS VACCINE PASSPORT SYSTEM
COMPLETELY.
SASKATCHEWAN, QUEBEC, HAVE DONE
THE SAME, THEY ARE GETTING RID
OF MOST OF THEIR COVID
RESTRICTIONS IN THE FACE OF
THIS, IN RESPONSE TO THIS.
WHEN YOU GO TOO FAR, PEOPLE TURN
AGAINST YOU.
IT WAS JUST A FEW DAYS AGO THAT
A GUY, THE LEADER OF CANADA'S
SUPPOSEDLY PRO-WORKER NDP PARTY,
SMEARED THE TRUCKERS AS RACISTS.
OF COURSE "THOSE THAT CLAIM THE
SUPERIORITY OF THE WHITE
BLOODLINE" -- WHAT A PIG.
IT'S ALWAYS THE SAME LINE.
BUT YESTERDAY, EVEN HE FINALLY
REALIZED THE SAME OLD SLANDER
DOESN'T WORK ANYMORE.
SO HE WENT TO PLAN B.
HE WENT FOR A FEDERAL PLAN TO
"EXIT THE PANDEMIC."
IN OTHER WORDS, HE CAVED IN THE
FACE OF PRINCIPAL HUMAN RIGHTS
PROTESTS.
THAT'S HOW THAT WORKS.
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF
JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S OWN LIBERAL
PARTY ARE NOW REBUKING
JUSTIN TRUDEAU.
ONE OF THOSE LAWMAKERS, A MEMBER
OF PARLIAMENT, DESCRIBED
JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S VACCINE MANDATE
AS "AN ATTEMPT TO WEDGE, TO
DIVIDE, AND TO STIGMATIZE.
I FEAR THAT THIS POLITICIZATION
OF THE PANDEMIC RISKS
UNDERMINING THE PUBLIC TRUST IN
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTIONS."
OH, YOU THINK?
YEAH!
WE IN AMERICA KNOW LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT.
WHO WON'T TRUST A DOCTOR WHEN
THE SMOKE SETTLES FROM CORONA?
SERIOUSLY.
BUT ON A POLITICAL LEVEL, ANYONE
WATCHING THIS UNDERSTANDS JUST
HOW PROFOUND THE BETRAYAL IS.
THE BETRAYAL.
BOTH IN CANADA AND IN THE
UNITED STATES.
SELF-DESCRIBED LIBERALS, THE ONE
WHO HAVE LECTURED YOU FOR
DECADES ABOUT THE NOBILITY OF
ORGANIZED LABOR, ARE NOW TAKING
THE SIDE OF MANAGEMENT, OF
STRIKEBREAKERS OVER STRIKING
WORKERS.
THEY ARE PLOTTING WITH MR. BURNS
ON THE SIMPSONS AS COPS HARASSED
AND ABUSED STRIKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
PRETTY SOON THEY WILL BE
DEMANDING SCABS, IF THEY WEREN'T
ALREADY BURIED IT IS SO DEEPLY
REVEALING.
SCRATCH A LIBERAL AND YOU'LL
FIND A FASCIST.
TODAY ON TWITTER, AND OBAMA DHS
OFFICIAL CALLED FOR VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE TRUCKERS.
/THEIR TIRES, SHE DEMANDED.
BUT DON'T STOP THERE.
CANCELED HER INSURANCE, SUSPEND
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSES.
PROHIBIT ANY FUTURE REGULATORY
CERTIFICATION.
HAVE WE LEARNED NOTHING, FELLOW
MEMBERS OF THE RULING CLASS?
THESE THINGS FASTER WHEN THERE
ARE NO CONSEQUENCES.
CRUSH THEM BEFORE THEY GET BIG
IDEAS.
SHE IS A NASTY LITTLE FASCIST
AND OF COURSE SHE IS A CNN
CONTRIBUTOR TOO.
OF COURSE SHE IS.
BUT WE WILL CONCEDE SHE IS RIGHT
ABOUT ONE THING.
THESE THINGS DO FESTER.
WHEN YOU IGNORE THE POPULATION'S
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS FOR LONG
ENOUGH, WHEN YOU DISMISS YOUR
OWN CITIZENS AS RACISTS AND
CONSPIRACY NUTS AND TRY TO SHUT
THEM DOWN FOR LONG ENOUGH, AT
SOME POINT, THEY ARE APT TO
REVOLT.
ONCE PEOPLE REALIZE THEY ARE
CITIZENS, NOT SERFS, YOU CAN'T
REALLY KNOW WHERE THINGS GO FROM
THERE.
AND IN THAT VEIN, TONIGHT, A
GROUP OF AMERICAN TRUCKERS
ANNOUNCED THEY WILL BEGIN A
NATIONWIDE TRUCK CONVOY IN THIS
COUNTRY STARTING NEXT MONTH IN
PROTEST AGAINST JOE BIDEN'S
VACCINE MANDATE.
THAT RALLY WILL BEGIN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ON MARCH 5TH
AND THEN IT WILL PROGRESSED
EASTWARD BY TRUCK TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., WHAT THEY
ASSUME IS STILL THE CAPITAL OF
THEIR COUNTRY.
HOW DOES THE SUPPOSEDLY PROUNION
WHITE HOUSE FEEL ABOUT THIS?
THEY ARE COMPLETELY PANICKED.
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE EXPOSING
THEIR OPINIONS?
THAT'S NOT ALLOWED.
SO JOE BIDEN, TAKING A PAGE FROM
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, HIS FRIEND TO
THE NORTH, HAS ALREADY SET THE
DEPARTMENT OF